yeah i've been self-sabotaging man that
[ __ ] is so destructive
you wouldn't believe the [ __ ] the things
my ego can't come up with i talked to
dame he said he loved me cause i'm so
destructive
i stay creating products that [ __ ] is so
productive these hoes are so reluctant
i might hit both for cousins i like my
women southern i like my diamonds
clustered
[ __ ] catch up like mustard shout out
to dj mustard no pun intended but i'm
taking over
okay thinking grow rich is my favorite
book
fake it till you make it it is all how
you make it look
i used to be underrated and overlooked
but even in covert times i'm overbooked
work smarter not harder the mantra to my
resolutions
[ __ ] i got no time for retribution take
the time i would have spent on payback
and spend that on execution
the best to do it tell me i'm the next
to do it shut out my [ __ ] babel he my
day one he ain't one he told me one day
i be packing stadiums
back when i couldn't pet gymnasiums i
always been nuts like macadamians
get on the beat and go tasmanian and
super saiyan and
my girl look like an alien she palladian
her [ __ ] tastes just like avian
she could win an avn about to buy all of
my friends mercedes benzes
he said put your energy in the music and
stop
all that other [ __ ] i was doing he told
me if i do it then my [ __ ] would pop
i thought my [ __ ] would flop like
christian rock i [ __ ] made too much
money
too much money type of money where they
do that for me type of money
where your friends become your enemies
and your enemies become your allies and
you learn to play both sides and you
create ties and pay ties to [ __ ] who
feel entitled or want a title
don't give them enough attention they
become your rival i don't trust no one
the devil behind behind a bible
and a smile sit back and watch your
money by you i'm getting too much money
too much money type of money where they
sue for nothing people purposely try to
push your buttons
sue you and go and get some liposuction
i deflate [ __ ] egos like breast
reductions
sent carl sherry a gift he got the
coaches here my vision crystal clear
my words are like magic i say what i
want and then that [ __ ] appears
yeah your fears is the only thing that
interferes
shout out to all my black men the tumors
and larry jackson's
most of the music on these playlists are
distractions i understand
algorithms interactions but how long can
we keep our people dancing
the neighborhoods turning whiter than
michael jackson gentrification while our
people get left with fractions shut out
my nickel
diamond down from brock hampton he told
me that my time was now
the road to success what i'm lying now
how you sleep on that [ __ ] without you
lying down
once i got my timing down and design the
sand and put the right people around i
got my [ __ ] up off the ground
breaking generational curses with these
purses
immersive these other [ __ ] barely
scratched the surface
you would have thought i signed the
universal the way the universe is in
alignment with my
carry la on my shoulder like purses
cribs can't furnish
cars get refurbished on the 56th floor i
don't even get no service
but i'm always in service
rich told me about everything that i hop
on take advantage of every platform
i treat business like masturbation
everything i touch i'm hands-on
focused on global expansion i get this
clovis [ __ ] but don't [ __ ] tell me to
put my mask on
this corona [ __ ] is a distraction and i
could go into detail
but no email will prevail the fbi
reading your dms and your emails
no vaccination i would rather just eat
kale and drink water
raw foods this chemistry no disease
could survive in alkalinity
seven told you the remedy and they
killed that [ __ ] take every dollar i
got
and i'm still that [ __ ] mind blowing my
phone of always worrying
i got news of my deal while she was in
surgery but i said to my retrograders
and mercury
i give a [ __ ] if i get accepted
commercially
cause my words gonna live on for
eternity
cause i don't believe in death third eye
to the [ __ ] sky
got my shackles realigned all i drink is
i can learn got my mind to get my money
over
my goddamn
damn i think i think we i think it's a
wrap right there right
first take first take yes
shout out to the la shout out to the
world shout out to my mama
shout out to my girl shout out to myself
no help
made a million myself this life
[Music]
you